well Karen let's start with the story
let's talk about the script and when you
first fell in love with it and how it
came into your hands yeah I was um I was
actually on a set of another film and
Andy Cohen who's also producer in the
movie is also the writers manager called
me and he pitched me some thriller that
didn't sound very good
and um said well what do you love what
do you have that you think is just
special and he told me that his client
had been working on this script and he
said oh but it's small and he sort of
downplayed it and said well if that's
the one you love send me that and I read
it and I just was desperate to make it
track down Tom and I think he was in
Montreal on vacation and just said I'm
your producer I have to be this movie
and what in Marc Webb's diverse
directing portfolio made him the perfect
guy for this story um I mean this is a
little movie and it's a bit of a
throwback film you know reminded me of
movies I grew up with um Kramer vs
Kramer mark and I talked about Paper
Moon movies that just don't really get
made that often anymore and so I felt
like the tone was really important to do
something that could be both funny and
dramatic but feel real and just
emotionally immersive so part of it was
just being in love with marks work and
really wanting and I was so impressed
with what he did with 500 days of summer
and wanting someone like that but it was
also knowing that if I compromise on who
the film maker was a the movie probably
wouldn't get made and B it probably
wouldn't get made well enough to be the
movie that as Tom Flynn says is a movie
that lots of people get to see and so
when he actually read it and said yes
that was and we were off to the races
well I was going to ask you you have
been acting most of your life since you
were very little so you've done a lot of
different things why did you want to
play Mary oh my goodness well I loved
Fred
I loved Mary I loved Frank I just loved
the entire script to it I just it really
moved me it was a really moving script
for me and I hope
that it's a moving movie for other
people like y'all and I just fell in
love with it after reading it because I
did the blacklist live reading which I
thought that if I did that if they
turned it into a movie then maybe I get
to be in the movie but to go through
another auditioning process which took
eight months and Wow
I just felt more emotionally attached to
this film that I have with any film you
really wanted it do you think you and
Mary have a lot in common well I think
that everyone has something in common
with Mary because we all feel alone or
different from time to time in our lives
so I think that we all have that in
common with Mary and anyways I am Mary
can you tell us a little bit about the
casting process and was Chris involved
like maybe in auditions to see if there
was chemistry you know there's there's a
sort of basic economy to getting a film
AIDS of course one of the first
questions was who's Frank and we needed
to figure out who Frank was in order to
know who Mary could be and once Chris
came into the onto the project we had
already started a actually international
casting search I think something like
900 girls we our casting director David
Rubin who is brilliant
along with Fox casting saw about 900
girls and we knew that we knew the movie
wouldn't work if we didn't have the
right Mary
but we also knew that we had to sort of
figure out that chemistry with whoever
played Frank so we did a chemistry read
in New York and McKenna was just I I
keep saying this but it's just because I
remember it so vividly you know when she
came in and there were a couple of girls
that are a few other girls that read as
well she came out if you remember this
but he just they had they were doing the
the breakfast cereal scene and they had
a little table and two chairs and yeah
she just had special Casey yeah we did
we briefed it up as you know we were
prepared and um he put her arm around
her she would say there was something he
did that was just felt so paternal
and there just seemed to be an instant
bond and they you know McKenna had great
rhythm they were riffing off each other
it was funny and then McKenna said
excuse me and left to come back go
prepare and come back in and do the
don't leave me scene and she basically
brought all of us to tears Chris was
just looking at the floor trying not to
cry mark lit crying I of course was
totally crying yeah so we sort of knew
that we we knew what we were doing them
yeah he nailed it
what why are your favorite themes from
the movie and and then what do you hope
what do you hope people remember mode
like like when they leave the theater
what do you really want them to think
about well I want them to leave feeling
happy and I want the movie to make them
feel good or make them cry make them
angry make them happy I want them to
leave the movie theater and Wow and I
just want them to think alike sometimes
people think that it must be so easy
like I did I thought that it was it must
be so easy for gifted children or gifted
people at all because they must be so
confident and so happy and have a lot of
friends at school and sure because very
know all the answer in their tests and
they know all the answer in the room
you're smarter and everybody must love
them but a lot of the time well
sometimes that's not the case yeah
sometimes we they feel different or they
feel sad and I want people to understand
that you should be nice to each other
even if we're different we should be
nice to each other no matter what like
if you see someone sitting alone at
recess then you should go say hi and ask
them they want to go play with you or if
you see someone sitting alone at a lunch
table you should play hey do you want to
have lunch with me you should be kind of
people because everyone has a story
everyone you have a story I have a story
everyone here has a story and that we
should all be kind to one another is
that away from the movie that is so true
I couldn't have said that better myself
well please help
we thank these lovely ladies and thank
you for your lovely film